merci la parole et à monsieur guy
geoffroy
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre je voudrais vous parler
d'aéroport et je forme le voeu d'obtenir
une réponse un peu plus consistante un
peu plus intéressante que celle dont
vous avez bien voulu faire le cadeau si
je peux me permettre à mes collègues
mais je ne veux pas vous parler de notre
dame des landes je voudrais vous parler
d'orly l'aéroport d'orly est un sujet de
préoccupation de l'ensemble des
plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'habitants qui sont soumis depuis de
nombreuses années à toutes les
interrogations à toutes les inquiétudes
est à tous les constats négatifs
il ya une vingtaine d'années c'était la
fameuse si on peut dire
trajectoire au contrôle qui visait à
l'initiative de la dg assez à faire en
sorte que l'atterrissage face à l'ouest
obéissent à une modification de
trajectoire qui aurait impacté de
nombreuses populations
ensuite c'est les tentatives de la dg
assez de modifier les trajectoires
d'atterrissage face à l'est à l'ouest
puis de décollage face à l'ess est
aujourd'hui c'est la jonction entre les
deux aérogares
cette jonction entre les deux aérogares
est présenté comme étant tout à fait
techniques et nos modifiant en rien le
volume d'activité de l'aérogare mais
certains s'inquiètent les élus les
populations sur le fait que peut-être
cette jonction serait en fait un
troisième aérogares ce qui voudrait dire
qu'on ne construit pas un troisième à
l'aérogare
si on n'a pas l'intention d'augmenter le
trafic monsieur le premier ministre
ma question est très simple face aux
nombreux élus de tous bords à toutes les
populations impactées par l'aéroport
d'orly est-ce que vous garantissez que
rien ne sera changé ni le volume ni
surtout le couvre-feu dont nous avons
besoin pour nous protéger face aux
agressions de plus en plus nombreuses de
l'ensemble des avions
la parole est à monsieur alain vidalies
secrétaire d'état chargé des transports
de la mer et de la paix
merci à monsieur le président monsieur
le député la question que vous posez
c'est une question grave puisque c'est
le problème au fond de la nécessité pour
nous de conjuguer en permanence
l'activité aérienne l'aéroport d'orly
mais on pourrait aussi parler charles de
gaulle avec avec aussi l'environnement
l'environnement il ya plusieurs sujets
qui se posent aujourd'hui 1 pour orly je
vais répondre très précisément à votre
question il ya plusieurs sujets qui se
posent notamment des sujets qui
concernent les modifications des survols
pour des raisons de sécurité et vous
savez que de ce point de vue là il ya eu
une large concertation
vous connaissez les problèmes en matière
de défense de l'intérêt général c'est
que on est arrivés à un accord mais que
chaque fois qu'on modifie la situation
finalement on impact d'autres
populations et donc l'art est difficile
mais la dg assez de ce point de vue là
n'entre pas dans le débat en disant
c'est à prendre ou à laisser il ya donc
toute une procédure aujourd'hui de
concertation assez complexe mais je
pense qu'on approche quand même assez de
la solution sur cette affaire qui pour
des raisons de sécurité modifie le
survol ensuite votre question très
précise c'est de dire est ce que les
travaux immobiliers qui sont en cours
sur l'aéroport si j'ai bien compris
peuvent être interprétés comme une
augmentation future de la capacité de
l'aéroport qui serait un choix de la
décision du gouvernement je vais être
très clair la réponse est non il n'y a
aucun projet d'augmentation de la
capacité et sur vos deux questions je
vais être très précis la capacité
restera la capacité actuelle
et deuxièmement le couvre-feu le
couvre-feu est compte tenu des impacts
pour la population un objectif
indépassable et jamais nous ne prendrons
des décisions sur orly qui remettront en
cause les deux règles que vous évoquez
je ne peux pas être plus précis dans ma
réponse
merci monsieur le ministre